bist du eigentlich ein Smash ich hoffe
ich hoffe ich weiß es auch nicht genau
wie ich eins bin sie wissen es
vielleicht auch nicht ja dann geht es
Ihnen wahrscheinlich wie uns sie sind
einfach sorry aber zu alt zumindest zu
alt für das Jugendwort des Jahres welche
Wörter zur Auswahl standen und was
möchte jetzt tatsächlich bedeutet unser
Reporter Manfred sedlbauer der wollte
das heute mal von Ihnen wissen
wild oder white gomimode Süd pro sus
Slay oder auch dicker sie alle standen
auf der Liste zum Jugendwort des Jahres
2022 aus Podest haben sie es allerdings
nicht geschafft darunter stehen übrigens
auch zwei Wörter mit denen auch sicher
die alte Generation etwas anfangen kann
auf Platz drei mit 24% gevotet Macher
also jemand der die Dinge umsetzt ohne
zu zögern mit 33% landet auf Platz zwei
bodenlos also so etwas wie mies oder
schlecht und auf Platz eins mit großem
Abstand 43 %. Trommelwirbel Smash Smash
ist ein Verb und bedeutet so viel wie
mit jemanden etwas anzufangen ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe das Wort
davon noch nie gehört aber vielleicht er
sie Jugendwort des Jahres wurde heute
gekürt was könnte das sein keine Ahnung
scheiße sind doch jetzt hier pro jo
Digger und blablabla in die Richtung
geht das
war nicht Grinch auch irgendwie mit
dabei Grinch
das war letztes Jahr
alter
[Applaus]
was bedeutet das keine Ahnung ich bin
auch nicht mehr so richtig jugendlich
insofern ich weiß es einfach nicht ja
für das Wort mache
ein Macher du bist ein Macher ich denke
schon ja Smash was könnte das bedeuten
keine Ahnung
ja fast spash weiß ich nicht hier ist
Mash wie Batman oder sonst wird keine
Ahnung
was meinst du könnte das bedeuten quasi
wenn irgendeine Person was mit meinen
mit der was anfangen würde quasi dann
sagt man sehr gut
okay das habe ich noch nie gehört nutzen
Sie das Wort öfter nein natürlich nicht
in meinem Alter und meine Enkel sind
noch zu klein nicht heute das erste Mal
gehört wirklich definitiv aber bringt
sich ein klar würden sie schon mal
geschmäscht
leider noch nicht
ja
glaube ich die alle wurdest du schon mal
geschmackt
ich glaube das haben wir alle mal oder
ich glaube ja
und sie schon mal gesmasht ja
warten sie 37 Jahre lang vor meiner Frau
das Wort Smash kommt übrigens von einem
dating-spiel Smash orchest was so viel
heißt wie mit jemandem etwas anfangen
wollen oder in weiterschicken wir sind
jetzt alle schlauer und unser Wortschatz
um ein Wort reicher
[Musik]